Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here
again to talk about language.
And you know, I've been thinking about
a number of things and language and
people and life, and I wanna do a
series of videos where I talk about
sort of the human side of language,
how important language is to our being.
And so I'm gonna talk
about language and travel.
I'm gonna talk about language and
history because history is a big part
of my interest in language learning.
I'm going to talk about ChatGPT and the
role of the teacher in the classroom.
And I'm going to talk about, uh, Elon
Musk's Neuralink, and I'm gonna do
this in four separate videos, but
today I'm gonna talk about travel.
One of the reasons is that
I'm going to be traveling.
I'm going to be in, uh,
Denmark from the six...
17th to the 19th of May.
Southern Sweden, the 21st, 22nd or so.
Stockholm, 24th, 25th.
And then I'm going to be in Poland
for a week, sort of 26th, seventh
through the 2nd of June, 1st of June.
So it would be great if we could, uh, if I
could meet some of my, uh, viewers there.
We could talk about our
interests and our enthusiasm,
hopefully for language learning.
Travel is kind of interesting
when it comes to language learning
because first of all, language
earning is a form of travel.
So every time I've learned a language,
I've explored other countries.
Uh, I may not be in those
countries, but I go there in a way.
I get interested in the countries,
I look up the map of the
countries, I look up pictures.
I get into the history of a country.
Uh, it's a form of traveling.
You're, you're traveling although
you're staying at home, you're
traveling to another world, another
world in time, another world in place.
So language learning is in itself
a form of travel, in my opinion.
Second thing about travel is the idea
that you might travel to the country.
Having that as a goal is
a tremendous motivator.
Uh, now, for example, I'm gonna be in
Denmark and Poland, so I, I went and
bought some audiobooks and eBooks.
I'm going through a history
of Denmark right now.
At some point, I'm gonna
switch over to Polish.
Uh, I'm not gonna be fluent when I get to
Denmark or Poland, but I'll have a much
better understanding of the language.
I'll be able to understand things
that are happening around me.
I will try to speak.
Um, it's gonna be
difficult, but I don't mind.
But having this level of understanding
is gonna make it more comfortable for
me to be in the language, to be in the
country where the language is spoken.
Also just listening to the audio
book and reading this book on Danish
history is again, as I said, a form of
travel, uh, traveling in the language.
And of course, the third thing about
travel is as many people point out,
you know, if you can be in the country
where the language is spoken, that's
the ultimate learning environment.
Assuming that you have a good enough
level in the language so that you
can take advantage, people are often
disappointed and it has happened to
me, that you go to the country...
I mean, I can think back to the
first time I went to Portugal.
I put a fair amount of effort into
learning Portuguese and I had Spanish.
And, uh, my Portuguese was not very
good, but everyone that I tried to
speak to spoke to me in English.
Uh, so I was unsuccessful.
But then I went back again and
studied some more Portuguese.
We, my wife and I, went to Portugal
the second time and I was able to
speak to people in Portuguese, so I,
I often mention this, it's important
to get your language up to a level
where it's good enough that people will
actually speak to you in that language.
And don't get discouraged if people
answer you in English because
random people in stores or on the
street, they are not your teachers.
And, uh, if they feel that their
English is a more efficient way of
communicating then that's what they
will in many cases, use, even though
you would like them to humor you in
the language that you are learning.
So, but still, even if you go there,
as I did in Portuguese and I failed,
I was unable to really find many
opportunities to use Portuguese.
And probably my Portuguese was not very
good despite the effort I had put in.
Nevertheless, I came away saying,
geez, I better improve my Portuguese so
that when I go again, I'll do better.
So to summarize, you know, travel language
learning itself is a form of travel.
Traveling in time and space and
language space, uh, language
learning can be a goal, a motivating
goal for learning a language.
You're planning to go to Mexico, you're
planning to go to China, you're planning
to go to Germany, Japan, so you're
gonna work very hard on the language.
And third of all, when you are there,
it can be an opportunity to use the
language and to improve in the language.
It may be difficult if your language isn't
up to the level that is needed in order
for people to want to communicate with
you in the language, but then that should
be additional motivation to improve.
So for all of those reasons, travel to
me is a big part of language learning.
I've, I'm sure that many of you
have had similar experiences.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.